this camera drone will give simeon
kochkin the overview he needs today he's
filming in yadrin in russia's chuvash
republic
the drone flies over what the activist
calls the empire of a local politician
filming the horse farm of the
businessman's son and his vacation home
on the river
kochkin cites this as an example of the
power and wealth of members of the
ruling party united russia
the family of a local mp has essentially
seized the riverbank for itself and
blocked it off
i plan to make a video about that and
make an official complaint by law the
riverbank has to be accessible to all
for four years simeon kochkin ran the
local campaign office of russia's most
prominent opposition politician and
anti-corruption activist alexey navalny
but in june a court declared the
russia-wide network of offices an
extremist organization effectively
banning it anyone connected to it could
face a prison sentence
in his home city of chebaksari simeon
kochkin organized opposition protests
against navain's arrest
the day before one of the protests the
police came knocking on kochkin's door
he streamed what was happening live on
instagram
guys is it the kind of country we live
in
everyone for vladimir putin
you really want this
the police arrested kochkin then a court
charged him with producing and
disseminating extremist material
it seems that for vladimir putin and the
russian authorities any connection with
alexey navani or his team has become a
red
that
flag
publicly called for mass riots and
publicly tried to lure miners into
taking part in street protests and that
is illegal in russia
it publicly gave instructions on how to
make molotov cocktails for example in
order to use them against the security
forces
he hasn't heard of instructions like
that he makes his videos to confront
regional politicians about corruption
and mismanagement
on youtube his videos regularly get
thousands of clicks his work carries on
navain's political strategy
kochkin's current goal is to convince as
many russians as possible to vote
strategically against the candidates
from the ruling united russia party the
opposition activist can't run in the
elections himself because of the
extremism charges against him
i've lost my job and i can't run for
office
is fighting to unite hundreds of
thousands of voters in his hometown of
chibak sari and the region
he has decided to work as a blogger
full-time and is collecting donations
online for his kremlin critical videos
at the moment he's earning the
equivalent of 300 euros per month hardly
enough to live on since the extremism
ruling against navain's organizations
many former coordinators from the
regional offices have left russia but
kochkin plans to keep blogging about
politics even after the
elections
will i continue to say that putin is a
disgusting president even after the
election that he should leave and that
he rewrote the constitution for his own
purposes of course
will i expect to be arrested yes
will i start up out of my seat when
someone unexpectedly rings my doorbell
yes
today kochkin is recording a teaser for
his upcoming video
he's convinced that across the country
dissatisfaction with vladimir putin and
his party runs much deeper than it seems
the regime can change at any moment
it's so unstable
even if the authorities are constantly
trying to prove to us that it's ironclad
even putin's people could topple him at
any moment
i really want changes to begin in our
country
in the next five years
or even earlier than that
is determined to keep believing in
change and he wants others to keep their
hopes up as well in his home region and
across russia
you